IMPORTS OF RUSSIAN OIL IN
RESPONSE TO THE WAR IN UKRAINE.
>> WE'RE BANNING ALL IMPORTS OF
RUSSIAN OIL AND GAS AND ENERGY.
THAT MEANS RUSSIAN OIL WILL NO
LONGER BE ACCEPTABLE AT U.S.
PORTS AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WILL DEAL ANOTHER POWERFUL BLOW
TO PUTIN.
THIS IS A MOVE WITH STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN CONGRESS
AND, I BELIEVE, IN THE COUNTRY.
AMERICA HAVE RALLIED TO SUPPORT
THEIR UKRAINIAN PEOPLE AND MADE
IT CLEAR, WE WILL NOT BE PART OF
SUBSIDIZING PUTIN'S WAR.
WE MADE THIS DECISION IN CLOSE
CONSULTATION WITH OUR ALLIES AND
PARTNERS AROUND THE WORLD,
PARTICULARLY IN EUROPE.
BECAUSE A UNITED RESPONSE TO
PUTIN'S AGGRESSION HAS BEEN MY
OVERRIDING FOCUS TO KEEP ALL
NATO AND ALL THE EU AND OUR
ALLIES TOTALLY UNITED.
WE'RE MOVING FORWARD,
UNDERSTANDING THAT MANY OF OUR
EUROPEAN ALLIES AND PARTNERS MAY
NOT BE IN A POSITION TO JOIN US.
THE UNITED STATES PRODUCES FAR
MORE OIL DOMESTICALLY THAN ALL
OF THE EUROPEAN COUNTRIES
COMBINED.
IN FACT, WE'RE A NET EXPORTER OF
ENERGY.
SO WE CAN TAKE THIS STEP WHEN
OTHERS CANNOT.
BUT WE'RE WORKING CLOSELY WITH
EUROPE AND OUR PARTNERS TO
DEVELOP A LONG-TERM STRATEGY TO
REDUCE THEIR DEPENDENCE ON
RUSSIAN ENERGY AS WELL.
OUR TEAMS ARE ACTIVELY
DISCUSSING HOW TO MAKE THIS
HAPPEN AND TODAY, WE REMAIN
UNITED, REMAIN UNITED IN OUR
PURPOSE TO KEEP PRESSURE
MOUNTING ON PUTIN AND HIS WAR
MACHINE.
THIS IS A STEP THAT WE'RE TAKING
TO INFLICT FURTHER PAIN ON
PUTIN.
BUT THERE WILL BE COST AS WELL
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES.
I SAID I WOULD LEVEL WITH THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE FROM THE
BEGINNING, AND WHEN I FIRST
SPOKE TO THIS, I SAID DEFENDING
FREEDOM IS GOING TO COST, IT'S
GOING TO COST US AS WELL IN THE
UNITED STATES.
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS
UNDERSTAND THAT ALIKE.
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS ALIKE
ARE CLEAR WE MUST DO THIS.
OVER THE LAST WEEK, I SPOKE TO
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY SEVERAL
TIMES TO HEAR FROM HIM ABOUT THE
SITUATION ON THE FWRGROUND AND
CONSULT AND CONTINUE TO CONSULT
EUROPEAN ALLIES AND SUPPORT FOR
UKRAINE AND THE UKRAINIAN
PEOPLE.
THUS FAR, WE PROVIDED MORE THAN
$1 BILLION IN SECURITY
ASSISTANCE TO UKRAINE.
SHIPMENTS OF DEFENSIVE WEAPONS
ARE ARRIVING IN UKRAINE EVERY
DAY FROM THE UNITED STATES AND
WE IN THE UNITED STATES ARE
COORDINATING DELIVERY OF OUR
ALLIES AND PARTNERS OF SIMILAR
WEAPONS FROM GERMANY TO FINLAND
TO THE NETHERLANDS.
WE'RE WORKING THAT OUT.
WE'RE ALSO PROVIDING
HUMANITARIAN SUPPORT FOR THE
UKRAINIAN PEOPLE.
THOSE IN UKRAINE AND WHO HAVE
FLED SAFELY TO NEIGHBORING
COUNTRY.
WE WORK WITH HUMANITARIAN
ORGANIZATIONS TO SURGE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF TONS OF FOOD,
WATER, MEDICAL SUPPLIES INTO
UKRAINE.
WITH MORE ON THE WAY.
OVER THE WEEKEND, I SENT
SECRETARY BLINKEN TO VISIT OUR
BORDER BETWEEN POLAND AND
UKRAINE AND TO MOLDOVA, TO SEE
WHAT THE SITUATION WAS FIRSTHAND
AND REPORT BACK.
GENERAL MILLI, CHAIRMAN OF THE
JOINT CHIEFS OF STAFF, OUR
DEFENSE DEPARTMENT, WAS ALSO IN
EUROPE MEETING WITH HIS
COUNTERPARTS AND ALLIES ON NATO,
THE EASTERN FLANK TO REASSURE
THEM THOSE COUNTRIES BORDERING
RUSSIA, THE NATO COUNTRIES, THAT
WE WILL KEEP OUR NATO
COMMITMENT, A SACRED COMMITMENT
OF ARTICLE V.
THE VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS WILL
TRAVEL TO MEET WITH ALLIES IN
POLAND AND ROMANIA AS WELL.
I MADE IT CLEAR.
THE UNITED STATES WILL SHARE IN
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF CARING FOR
THE REFUGEES SO THAT THE COSTS
DO NOT FALL ENTIRELY ON THE
EUROPEAN COUNTRY'S BORDERING
UKRAINE.
AND YESTERDAY, I SPOKE WITH MY
COUNTERPARTS AT FRANCE, GERMANY
AND THE UNITED KINGDOM ABOUT
RUSSIA'S ESCALATING VIOLENCE
AGAINST UKRAINE AND THE STEPS
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE TOGETHER
WITH OUR ALLIES AND PARTNERS
AROUND THE WORLD TO RESPOND TO
THIS AGGRESSION.
WE ARE ENFORCING THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT PACKAGE OF ECONOMIC
SANCTIONS IN HISTORY, AND IT'S
CAUSING SIGNIFICANT DAMAGE TO
RUSSIA'S ECONOMY.
IT HAS CAUSED RUSSIAN ECONOMY TO
FIGHT.
THE RUSSIAN RUBLE NOW DOWN TO
50%, SINCE PUTIN ANNOUNCED HIS
WAR.
ONE RUBLE IS NOW WORTH LESS THAN
ONE AMERICAN PENNY.
ONE RUBLE, LESS THAN ONE
AMERICAN PENNY AND PREVENTING
RUSSIA'S CENTRAL BANK FROM
PROPPING UP THE RUBLE AND TO
KEEP ITS VALUE UP.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT NOW.
WE CUT THE RUSSIAN'S LARGEST
BANKS FROM THE INTERNATIONAL
FINANCIAL SYSTEM AND IT'S
CRIPPLED THEIR ABILITY TO DO
BUSINESS WITH THE REST OF THE
WORLD.
IN ADDITION, WE'RE CHOKING OFF
RUSSIA'S ACCESS TO TECHNOLOGY
LIKE SEMICONDUCTORS THAT ARE,
AND SAP.
IT'S ECONOMIC STRENGTH AND
WEAKENED ITS MILITARY FOR YEARS
TO COME.
MAJOR COMPANIES ARE PULLING OUT
OF RUSSIA ENTIRELY, WITHOUT EVEN
BEING ASKED, NOT BY US.
OVER THE WEEKEND, VISA,
MASTERCARD, AMERICAN EXPRESS,
THEY ALL SUSPENDED THEIR
SERVICES IN RUSSIA, ALL OF THEM.
JOINING A GROWING LIST OF
AMERICAN AND GLOBAL COMPANIES
FROM FORD TO NIKE TO APPLE, THEY
SUSPENDED THEIR OPERATIONS IN
RUSSIA.
THE U.S. STOCK EXCHANGE HAS
HAULED IN TRADING OF MANY
RUSSIAN SECURITIES.
IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR, UNITED
AGAINST RUSSIA'S VICIOUS WAR OF
CHOICE.
THE U.S. DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
HAS ASSEMBLED A DEDICATED TASK
FORCE TO GO AFTER THE CRIMES OF
RUSSIAN OLIGARCHS AND JOINING
WITH OUR EUROPEAN ALLIES TO FIND
AND SEIZE THEIR YACHTS, LUXURY
APARTMENTS AND ALL THEIR GAINS
TO MAKE SURE THEY SHARE IN THE
PAIN OF PUTIN'S WAR.
THESE, BY THE WAY, ARE GIANT
YACHTS.
YOU PUT SOMETHING IN, I THINK I
READ ONE WAS OVER 400 FEET LONG.
I MEAN, THIS IS WORTH HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
THE DECISION TODAY IS NOT
WITHOUT COST HERE AT HOME.
PUTIN'S WAR IS ALREADY HURTING
AMERICAN FAMILIES AT THE GAS
PUMP.
SINCE PUTIN BEGAN HIS MILITARY
BUILD-UP AT THE KUKRAINIAN
BORDER, THE PRICE OF GAS IN
AMERICA WENT UP 75 CENTS AND
WITH THIS ACTION IS GOING TO GO
UP FURTHER.
I'M GOING TO DO EVERYTHING I CAN
TO MINIMIZE PUTIN'S PRICE HIKE
HERE AT HOME.
IN COORDINATION WITH PARTNERS,
WE ALREADY ANNOUNCED WE RELEASE
60 MILLION BARRELS OF OIL FROM
OUR JOINT OIL RESERVES.
HALF OF THAT, 30 MILLION IS
COMING FROM THE UNITED STATES.
AND WE'RE TAKING STEPS TO ENSURE
THE RELIABLE SUPPLY OF GLOBAL
ENERGY.
ALSO GOING TO KEEP WORKING WITH
EVERY TOOL AT OUR DISPOSAL TO
PROTECT AMERICAN FAMILIES AND
BUSINESSES.
LET ME SAY THIS.
TO THE OIL AND GAS COMPANIES AND
TO THE FINANCE FIRMS, WE
UNDERSTAND PUTIN'S WAR AGAINST
THE PEELOPLE OF UKRAINE IS CAUSG
PRICES TO RISE.
THAT'S SELF-EVIDENT.
BUT IT'S NO EXCUSE TO EXERCISE
EXCESSIVE PRICE INCREASES.
PADDING PROFITS OR ANY KIND OF
EFFORT TO EXPLOIT THIS SITUATION
OR AMERICAN CONSUMERS, EXPLOIT
THEM.
RUSSIA'S AGGRESSION IS COSTING
US ALL.
AND IT'S NO TIME FOR
PROFITEERING OR PRICE GOUGING.
I WANT TO BE CLEAR ABOUT WHAT
WE'LL NOT TOLERATE.
BUT I'LL ALSO A WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THOSE FIRMS AND OIL
AND GAS INDUSTRIES PULLING OUT
OF RUSSIA AND JOINING OTHER
BUSINESSES LEADING BY EXAMPLE.
THIS IS A TIME WHEN WE HAVE TO
DO OUR PART.
AND MAKE SURE WE'RE NOT TAKING,
WE'RE NOT TAKING ADVANTAGE.
LOOK, LET ME BE CLEAR ABOUT TWO
OTHER POINTS.
FIRST, IT'S SIMPLY NOT TRUE THAT
MY ADMINISTRATION OR POLICIES
ARE HOLDING BACK DOMESTIC ENERGY
PRODUCTION.
IT'S SIMPLY NOT TRUE.
EVEN AMID THE PANDEMIC,
COMPANIES IN THE UNITED STATES
PUMP MORE OIL DURING MY FIRST
YEAR IN OFFICE THAN DURING MY
PREDECESSOR'S FIRST YEAR.
WE'RE APPROACHING A RECORD
LEVELS OF OIL AND GAS PRODUCTION
IN THE UNITED STATES AND WE'RE
ON TRACK TO SET A RECORD OF
WORLD PRODUCTION NEXT YEAR.
IN THE UNITED STATES, 90% OF
ONSHORE OIL PRODUCTION TAKES
PLACE ON LAND THAT ISN'T OWNED
BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
AND OF THE REMAINING 10% THAT
OCCURS ON FEDERAL LABND, THE OI
AND GAS INDUSTRY THAT HAS
MILLIONS OF ACRES LEASED, 9,000
PERMITS TO DRILL NOW, RIGHT NOW,
YESTERDAY, LAST WEEK, LAST YEAR.
THEY HAVE 9,000 TO DRILL ONSHORE
THAT ARE ALREADY PROVED.
SO LET ME BE CLEAR.
LET ME BE CLEAR.
THEY'RE NOT USING THEM FOR
PRODUCTION NOW.
THAT'S THEIR DECISION.
THESE ARE THE FACTS.
WE SHOULD BE HONESTABOUT THE
FACTS.
SECOND, THIS CRISIS IS A STARK
REMINDER TO PROTECT OUR ECONOMY
OVER THE LONG-TERM, WE NEED TO
BECOME ENERGY INDEPENDENT.
I'VE HAD NUMEROUS CONVERSATIONS
OVER THE LAST MONTHS WITH
EUROPEAN FRIENDS HOW THEY HAVE
TO WEAN THEMSELVES OFF OF
RUSSIAN OIL.
IT'S JUST NOT TENABLE.
IT SHOULD MOTIVATE US TO
ACCELERATE THE TRANSITION OF
CLEAN ENERGY.
THIS IS A PERSPECTIVE THAT'S OUR
EUROPEAN ALLY SHARE AND IN THE
FUTURE, WHERE TOGETHER, WE CAN
ACHIEVE GREATER INDEPENDENCE.
LOOSENING ENVIRONMENTAL
REGULATIONS AND PULLING BACK
CLEAN ENERGY INVESTMENT WON'T,
WILL NOT LOWER ENERGY PRICES FOR
FAMILIES.
BUT TRANSFORMING OUR ECONOMY TO
RUN ELECTRIC VEHICLES POWERED BY
CLEAN ENERGY WITH TAX CREDITS TO
HELP AMERICAN FAMILIES WINTERIZE
THEIR HOMES AND USE LESS ENERGY,
THAT WILL, THAT WILL HELP.
AND IF WE CAN, IF WE DO WHAT WE
CAN, IT WILL MEAN THAT NO ONE
HAS TO WORRY ABOUT PRICE OF GAS
PUMP IN THE FUTURE.
THAT WILL MEAN TYRANTS LIKE
PUTIN WON'T BE ABLE TO USE
FOSSIL FUELS AS WEAPONS AGAINST
OTHER NATIONS.
AND IT WILL MAKE AMERICA A WORLD
LEADER, MANUFACTURING AND
EXPORTING CLEAN ENERGY
TECHNOLOGIES OF THE FUTURE TO
COUNTRIES ALL AROUND THE WORLD.
THIS IS THE GOAL WE SHOULD BE
RACING TOWARD.
OVER THE LAST TWO WEEKS,
UKRAINIAN PEOPLE HAVE INSPIRED
THE WORLD.
I MEAN THAT IN A LITERAL SENSE.
THEY INSPIRED THE WORLD WITH
THEIR BRAVERY, PATRIOTISM,
DEFIANT DETERMINATION TO LIVE
FREE.
PUTIN'S WAR, PUTIN'S WAR HAS
CAUSED AN ENORMOUS SUFFERING AND
NEEDLESS LOSS OF LIFE OF WOMEN,
CHILDREN, EVEN IN UKRAINE.
BOTH UKRAINE AND, I MIGHT ADD,
RUSSIANS.
UKRAINIAN LEADERS AS WELL AS
LEADERS AROUND THE WORLD HAVE
REPEATEDLY CALLED FOR A
CEASE-FIRE.
FOR HUMANITARI